عندما أرسم أعمالي ، أشعر
بحرية تامة
[موسيقى
] بصراحة ، بدأت أعاني من أعراض
اكتئاب ما بعد الولادة
والقلق بشدة بعد ولادة
ابني الثاني ،
أتذكر أن صرخاته كانت بمثابة
محفز بالنسبة لي ولم أستطع فهمها
لماذا كان قلبي يتسابق
فجأة لماذا شعرت فجأة بالانفصال ، تم تشخيصي لأول مرة
بالاضطراب ثنائي القطب في يوليو
من عام 2011.
شرح الطبيب النفسي المتناول
خطة علاج
سأبدأ بها مع هذا
الدواء ، فقد
اقترح معالجتي أن  لقد ملأت أو
صنعت شيئًا بنّاءً
بيدي ،
أتذكر فقط وضع الطلاء على
يدي وعلى القماش
وتحريكه من مكان لآخر ، شعرت بأنني
مختلف تمامًا عما كنت عليه قبل
لحظة تحول حقًا منذ أن
بدأت الرسم في عام 2012 ،
ربما فعلت أكثر من  ألف
قطعة قمت بتأسيس مجموعة فنون سارة لدعم
وتضخيم عمل النساء السود
والبنيات والفنانين غير الثنائيين الذين في
المقام الأول  أعمل في التجريد لأنني
كنت أبحث عن شيء ما
زالت اللوحة العلاجية هي أنها مهنتي
لكنها في الحقيقة لا تزال علاجًا